but then it happened again and the
doctor said he's dehydrated but but look
at this this is just last week
that's one of my thoughts about what
running for re-election in 2026.
oh sure
did you hear the question Senator
running for re-election in 2026
all right I'm sorry you all we're gonna
need a minute
okay
somebody else have a question please
speak up
I mean it really is just insane it's as
if I was speaking and then
Dave Dave
if somebody has a question please speak
up oh okay
you see what we did there guys Emmy
award-winning Reuben report
Alex
anything else on this
It's just sad I mean he needs to really
get some if that's how he's acting in
public imagine what he's like behind
closed doors I mean I only imagine that
is much worse and probably has a nurse
to them all the time I mean really sad
Isabel what do you what do you just sort
of like the generational shift on this
that it's this baby boomer gender that
he's not even baby boomer and he's he's
from I guess what they call the greatest
Generation before that but they are hung
uh hanging on so long or I guess he's
the top of the Boomer supposedly but
whatever it is like these people are
just hanging on so long that they
haven't let the Gen X guys the the say
35 to 55 year olds who should be in
charge right now really take over thus
it pushes your generation back further
and and that really is almost the
Genesis of all of our problems right now
it is and I always like to remind myself
when I get frustrated thinking How could
somebody possibly just want to keep
doing this over and over for the rest of
their life the only thing that's more
corruptable than money is power and
absolute power corrupts absolutely which
is why you see our second oldest Senate
since 1789 our third oldest house uh in
all time American history because these
people grab onto power and they just
can't let go and eventually do become a
vessel for other people to seek power in
Washington DC I never noticed this in
that second clip until I just saw it
again from Mitch McConnell that his aide
his staffer actually Winks at the camera
we're gonna need a minute guys so it's
this open joke that we're all aware of
and everyone's thinking but nobody's
willing to talk about it meanwhile 70
percent of Americans think that the Two
Front Runners for president are too old
to be president we think that our
Congress is far too old to continue
holding on to power but a generational
shift doesn't look like handing the
reins even to Millennials or gen Z like
most people think it literally is
handing the reins to people my parents
age to take over the country and we're
still uncomfortable doing that in
Washington for some reason yeah it's
also interesting you know you mentioned
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
it's like McConnell has had so much
power for so long and yet in those
freeze-up moments and we've seen it with
Biden too there is this fear in there
because he knows something is wrong the
people around him don't care and it
becomes this self-fulfilling prophecy we
will basically run this guy into the
ground